[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben ich freue mich dass wir
zum heutigen video eingeschaltet habe
denn ich habe fast richtig leckeres für
euch und zwar sind das gefüllte
blätterteigtaschen mit leckerem reis
hackfleisch und gemüse ich sag's gleich
vorweg ich habe von der füllung die
doppelte menge zubereitet ich sage euch
aber hier im video die einfache menge
ihr benötigt weil leser gemüsebrühe zwei
packungen blätterteig hier sind zwei
gläser reiht sie braucht aber ein glas
frei zwei esslöffel öl paprika flocken
salz und pfeffer 2 esslöffel butter 3
klein geschnittene möhren 100 gramm
erbsen ich habe tief bei ärzten genommen
dann habe ich noch 100 gramm mandeln die
werde ich gleich noch an rüsten 150
gramm cashewkerne die sind bereits
gerüstet
300 gramm hackfleisch zuallererst werden
die gestifteten mandeln gerüstet dafür
gibt er sie einfach in eurer heiße
pfanne und rührt dabei ständig um
sobald wir dann farbe angenommen haben
nimmt er sich vom herbst in die gleiche
falle gebt ihr dann das öl und grafikers
zwei standen an
[Musik]
danach kommen die gewürze hinzu und
alles wird noch mal gut miteinander
verrührt den reis habe ich unter
fließendem kalten wasser abgespült das
ist auch sehr wichtig damit die stärke
ausgespielt wird und der reichen und
herrlich klebt und er bietet noch zwei
minuten lang mit gerüstet und jetzt noch
die gemüsebrühe zugegeben
[Musik]
jetzt bittet den herd auf die niedrigste
stufe stellen damit das ganze garen kann
86 8 bis 10 minuten das wasser ist hier
noch nicht ganz verdampfte reist auch
noch nicht gar geben sie aber schon das
gemüse hin zu früheren das noch mal
alles miteinander und geben noch mal den
deckel drauf und jetzt geht alles noch
mit geschlossenem deckel gar gekocht ca
80 10 minuten lang ihr könnt den deckel
ab und zu anheben umrühren und schauen
ob der reis gar ist nun kommt die butter
mit hinzu die gebe ich einfach oben
drauf schließe den deckel damit er schön
schmelzen kann und nach drei minuten ca
höre ich das ganze darum zu guter letzt
kommen noch die nutzer reihen die
cashewkerne und die mandeln wird noch
mal alles gut untergerührt und dann ist
die füllung auch schon fertig
nun nehmen wir uns unseren blätterteig
teilen ihn in sechs teile anschließend
sehen wir uns einen teil geben dass zwei
esslöffel von der füllung drauf und
verschließen oder verendet
[Musik]
die unis werden dann noch mit eigelb
bestreichen damit wir auch eine schöne
farbe abbekommen
wer mag kann sie jetzt noch nicht
mangeln der koreanisch wird das
besonders schön also gebt euch am besten
ein paar auf und dann kommen sie auch
schon auf das backblech und werden
gebacken
nach 20 minuten sind sie dann auch schon
fertig und die traditionell immer mit
joghurt verwirrt und falls ihr glaubt es
reicht euch nicht als hauptspeise doch
glaub mir das ist keine beilage also
zwei bubis sättigen von wehr und wenn
ihr das ganze nach machen möchte dann
schreib mir doch gerne wie euch das
geschmacks habe ich bin sehr gespannt
auf eure kommentare und übermorgen gibts
schon wieder das nächste rezept video
hinterlassen wir doch gern ein abo wenn
ihr nicht mehr verpassen möchte
[Musik]